ماذا قرات وليد معنا وليد العمري مدير
مكتب الجزيره وليد ماذا قرات فيما قاله
نتنياهو وما قاله ايضا
[موسيقى]
هذا مؤشر اذا ما اجملنا ما تحدث به ولماذا
تحدث الان على ان امور الوساطه التي تجري
بدات ربما تقترب من انضاج تسويه
تنهي هذا القتال الجاري لذا اقول بان
اعلان كلاهما تكرر نفس الجمله بانها هذه
معركه وان رغبتها ان تنتهي قريبا ولكن
اسرائيل حققت ما تريده من ورائها وجاهزه
للاستمرار اذا استدعى الامر اذا ما عدنا
الى المرات السابقه التي كان يكون فيها
جولات قتال من هذا القبيل كان دائما يكون
هناك مؤتمر صحفي من هذا المستوى للقاده
الاسرائيليين يشيرون فيه الى الرغبه في
الهدوء وانهم حققوا الاهداف اللازمه لذا
خلاصه الحديث ان الامور تتجه نحو التهدئه
على الاغلب وان الوساطه التي تنشط فيها
مصر وقطر والامم المتحده والولايات
المتحده
يبدو انها تقترب فعلا من انضاج اتفاق خلال
الساعات المقبله
وواضح من تصريحاتهما ايضا مثل اريد ان
يبعث برساله داخليه الى المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ان علاقته بوزير الدفاع جيده
وليس كما كانت في المرات السابقه فهو من
هنا يحاول ان يحقق امرين الاول نحو
الاسرائيليين يقول لهم بان الضربه التي تم
توجيهها للجهاد الاسلامي غير مسبوقه مثل
ما ردده هو ووزير الدفاعة وانهم يبحثان او
يريدان ان تكون هذه المعركه قد اوشكت على
النهايه لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي لديه من
القدرات والامكانيات اذا ما اقتضى الامر
ان يواصل ان يواصل ويوجه المزيد من
الضربات وهذا ما كان يكرره القاده
الاسرائيليون في كل جولات المعارك مع قطاع
غزه خلال الفتره السابقه هذا امر غايه في
الاهميه خاصه وانهما
ظهر امام
الاعلام من مقر وزاره الدفاع والاجهزه
الامنيه والجيش المعروف الكرياب في تل
ابيب وذلك بعد اجتماعات تجاور امنيه
الاولى اجراها وزير الدفاع مع قاده
الاجهزه الامنيه تحديدا الامن العام
الشباب الذي كانوا له المديح الكثير وايضا
وقاده الجيش والثانيه كانت لنتنياهو ايضا
مع وزير الدفاع ومع كبار حتى وصلوا
ومستشار الامن القومي حتى وصلوا الى ذلك